vanessa bryant just dropped off her
oldest daughter natalia bryant at
college and said the whole thing was
rough on wednesday the 39 year old wife
of the late kobe bryant dropped off her
18 year old daughter at the university
of southern california and shared this
snap on instagram with the teen and her
younger daughters four-year-old bianca
and two-year-old capri as they said
their goodbyes the caption today was
rough this was before the tears came
down missing forever i love you natalya
bryant be epic and fight on
and natalya she slid into the comments
of her mom's post writing simply i love
you
but before vanessa dropped off her
firstborn it seems they squeezed in a
little celebratory family dinner check
out these pics vanessa posted sharing a
delicious meal with her girls and some
pals she tagged natalya in the caption
with another fight on and judging by the
menu seems like they were dining at
sushi hotspot nobu and enjoyed some
edamame charred peppers and mini tacos
natalya first committed to joining usc
back in march and vanessa revealed the
news on instagram sharing the moment
they found out she got accepted
she captioned the post in part quote i
wish daddy and gigi were physically here
to celebrate but i know they're here in
spirit shortly after that natalia
confirmed the news posting this snap to
instagram alongside the caption see you
soon usc fight on and while the college
drop-off might have been emotional it
could have been a lot tougher
back in january the proud mama posted
this pic of natalia in a new york
university sweatshirt and in the caption
she said she was doing what mamas do
trying to convince her daughter not to
fly too far from the nest she wrote in
part quote nyu is one of her top schools
i will do my best to keep her and cali
just like i kept her daddy here looks
like vanessa got her wish attending usc
means natalia is just a short drive away
from home
[Music]
you